the ebony enchantress at the finale
night
i mean what does this moment mean to you
oh my god i missed everything i'm so
happy to be here
i worked real hard to get here and it
just means everything
like come on i made it to the top four
rupaul's drag race what what
i'm good you could be a little better
get a crown on that head
i mean you're right about that you
getting right right right
what would that step mean to you to be
crowned america's next drag superstar
it wouldn't mean the work has been done
it means that my heart
you know it's received and it's worthy
of carrying a crown
like it would mean everything to me you
know i i grew up watching this show so
to be part of
this legacy of queens who come through
and change culture
i mean what an honor you know what i'm
saying like it would
literally mean everything to me well
you're
crowned or not you're part of the legacy
now yeah
[Music]
don't let the smooth taste fool you baby
since episode one episode two
people were like there's your winner
crowner already there she is
does that put added pressure on you is
it more motivation how do you process
that it was a little bit of both it was
a little bit about the motivation to
you know keep being at the level that i
came in out and growing
but also the pressure of i didn't want
to let anyone down and i didn't want
people to
you know think less of me in a way but
that was just me being like no you need
me
so that's really all that matters at
first it was a lot but coming through
now it's kind of though
that's don't don't go back to where he
was at when sometimes then
it's all good you tell that inner
saboteur
good day
i just the outpouring of love i mean
lizzo's rocking your merch
haley williams gave you kudos for your
paramore inspired look what's it like to
receive
feedback from these people who i only
imagine are kind of idols in your life
oh yeah um it's kind of surreal i was
like oh these girls see me
they they they're me they know they have
a new channel just starting so
it's i'm always just humbled by i don't
know it's probably before the answer but
it really is surreal because it's like
these people are
loving what you're doing that is crazy
one rupaul
really loved what you did all season
long
and i'm here for the throne
where at how much mamaroo had fallen in
love with you
in the moment or did you learn from
watching it back
oh no i was aware
she she's not one to hide her emotions
i'll say that so i was
very much aware of how she felt about me
and that
you would think it would make you be
like oh i gotta keep making that problem
it just made me
be like i'm gonna go on this runway i'm
about to turn it i might do this
challenge except
one but um i'm mad
uh it just made me more vigorous to be
like let's do it let's turn it let's
make her proud
i want to see that smile baby i want to
keep my light up like it was like that
so just it was very apparent and i
wanted to strive for that everything for
sure i
imagine you're bringing that energy to
the finale in one word
what can we expect at this finale oh for
me
[Laughter]
break down this look for me today this
is a mix of like everything you showed
us simone to being
absolutely i wanted to be you know
flirty cute and fun for this one
so i'm in a point [ __ ]
the lovely mosquito thank you jeremy uh
shout out and you know just rocking and
be the only coring
on the runway on the red carpet
it's the perfect dress for a for a gig
in the future collect those tips you got
and put them right here
right here right here wherever maybe
yeah under there too anywhere they'll
think
um can you give me a factory
for good measure oh i got you i
i own 51 of the flag victory were you
aware that you went into this voice and
did this character olivia called you out
a little bit on it
on the last challenge listen dragons by
having fun and
i it comes from i was always
told to speak a certain way because you
know i'm in the south you know we gotta
move around so when i'm in drag i like
to play i like to say the english
language a little bit so it was very
conscious choices i made well
lasting impression choices too i mean i
think you're in
the drag race lexicon history now for
at least a factory and a number of other
things you got
to bring messages to the runway too
talk to me about those conscious choices
you made to make sure every time you
stepped out on that stage you were
showing something and saying something
you always want to have fun but i did
think about the runways
as a way to communicate you know you're
not really talking unless you're doing
voiceovers but this is a way to show who
you are so i was very conscious of that
and i wanted to have fun i wanted to be
myself
but i also wanted to say something and
those choices i'm happy i made them they
were hard
but um i think it's important especially
the times weren't that i didn't just
want to be a pretty thing on the runway
i mean that's easy you know
so i wanted to just say something and to
show myself and
um express myself through clothes that's
that's obviously what i like to do so um
yeah that was my mission and i think i
think i did a pretty good job i think
mission accomplished
i want to talk about some of the
highlights of the season maybe some of
the low lights too
uh get your take on some stuff what was
your favorite fashion moment from this
season it could be yours or anyone
else's
oh they're definitely mine i'm gonna do
my do-rag i always think of my direct
that that reminds me at home that's just
right here for me
i love my um
they're all my babies i love my
fascinator obviously
and i love the beast look with real ones
i don't think people are ready for that
one i don't even know if i was
practicing that one but i had a great
time
i think you were ready for it rupaul
wasn't ready for it was like
yeah i've said it once and i'll say it
again
your best defense against financial ruin
is a side ponytail on the on the flip
side of the highs
what was the fashion low for you this
season worst look of season my
worst look i don't think i could my
worst
compared to the other ones but um
okay although for me i have to say it
was probably the yellow one
that one was the low for me
i mean i was not expecting you to name
one of your looks i thought you were
going to call out somebody else's
one of the other girls oh i don't want
to do that that's mean
there's
[Laughter]
what was the quote of the season for you
i think it was um
blood sugar and then what was the lip
sync of the season for you the favorite
lip sync for your life
to see denali and kimura's lip sync that
was the first time
that we um many of us got to like see a
show
[Music]
so like that was like the first one we
had all of us were together and just
like to see them go
at it that was crazy it was so good and
then any
apologies to make or regrets from the
season
i'm a great i regret not one thing
and i apologize
that has been the consistent answer
across the top four today and i think it
speaks to
the family bond essentially bond of this
season is like we didn't really have a
villain
we had drama but it wasn't like drama
drama like
yeah no it wasn't
all of us are cool like being it's just
you know we came in to have a good time
and i think also
just the times we were in like it just
wasn't there was no time for it you know
and of course we bickered you saw that
but we love each other we really do
and um i don't regret anything and i
love everyone on the chat so
i'm good hopefully a crown
appears on your head in the near future
nothing more
if it does if it doesn't would you come
back and do an all-stars
when i come back of course now will they
have me that's the question
the invitation's already out i would
like to see you and gigi compete against
each other
oh y'all wanna don't be almost mama
that's what i want you all
to [ __ ] prom on these screens look after
you
i just want to i want to see what that
looks like
does the house of avalon stand after
something like that
coming for us oh i see it
uh pride is coming up and hopefully
things will look a little more normal
this year than they did last year
right how are you expecting to celebrate
pride and what does pride this year
especially mean
oh my god i think hopefully god willing
um
it's celebrating with the fans you know
i
would love to experience the world i've
always wanted to travel so to travel
around
the country in the world experience
different types of pride
peoples that'll be really nice but pride
this year i think it means a lot more
every time
because you know we were kind of strict
over here and some months
of connection and so i think it's made
people be very much more conscious
of how special that is and how
specifically our community is special
and
how you know we love each other so i
think it's gonna be
it's gonna be a good time it's gonna be
a wild time i'm ready
and you can get out there and meet all
the drag race viewers who have been
crushing on you for months now i know
and i'm excited to see it
how do you feel how do you receive that
attention like the
out of drag attention oh god i
i am a little bit more shocked out of
drive
so i it's gonna be a little weird at
first i'm not gonna lie but i welcome i
will call up
checking if blood sugar's low while
we're getting people to the factory
doing all the things and making sure
deborah is there ready to go
jabar will be keeping everyone in line
check
oh no no not a little dab dab no we're
scratching that diva
it's deborah now
you